DR THRUSSIAN
VANI F
MTOY RUSSIA.
BACK.EROFFENSIVE
INMEAL MEN CHAIROF
THE JOINCHF.
CARAHI>> THEY L TE.
UKRAINIAMY THE UKRAINIAN
E DONE SO EVENHOUMBERED,SEE
COCOF SSD WH
TIVEWHATS  MY ANROPES ISS THENN
I LITILLOF UKR HCONTINUET ACCOR
TOH  BADLY H FORCEHA PFO
THE TT NOWWE
NSTRAINEOPPOSED,HE'LL TRY TO
THIS ISL OF A FIR PUTI
HAS TO  STOPPEDI DON'T TH
.INK HE TO BEOR
SETTLE WITT TOS
UKRAIN TO OPPOAN
COUNTEROFFENSIVE T SPIRIT IER WL
THERE.
THEY HAVE TO H
ON BALANCE, YOU KNOWK E UKRAINI
INTO, YOU  G TIM D
THE DTO SUF
SUS NEVEN?K THAT'S THE
IF YOU'VE DEALWIICITHUANIAEY
NE
IF
EVEN IF RUSSIA DOESN'TUSSIA.
EY BYUTRT
IS WHERE THE BULK OF T ALL THE C
ADMIRAL, FORMER  COMER
HE'S BEEHETES AN OPEUP CANT THE.
A AGNCDID AROUND PF SE
WAR. DO N'T COME AS AS AN
IT'SORE NOTICEISIN
VIEW?
TO UNLOCK ODESA?
THRRTHAT YOU'RE SPEAKING O SEA
THE  T SEATH ON THE RUN AN TANDA
VID TH N
GOINGO RNLDAR IIINOW SEE ATED
LANE SO WE CAN GCONTROSEA